IS PUTTING MONEY ONTO BE THE
DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE.
BUT FIRST, I WANT TO PUT MY
CONVERSATION WITH IVANKA TRUMP
INTO THE BROADER ECONOMIC
CONTEXT.
THE BIG DOMESTIC POLICY
QUESTION FOR 2020 IS THIS, HOW
TO KEEP THE TRUMP ECONOMY
GROWING.
THE ESTABLISHMENT STATE MEDIA
CAMPAIGNS THAT TALK TO AMERICA
INTO A RECESSION SEEMS TO BE
WORKING.
WE SAW THE BIGGEST DROP IN
CONFIDENCE AMONG CEOS FOR
SEVEN YEARS.
OH,  THERE'S ONE PROBLEM,
NOBODY TOLD THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
LOOK AT THIS HEADLINE IN
AXION, THEY ARE SPENDING.
ALL THE INDICATIONS ARE THAT
THIS WILL BE A BLOCKBUSTER
HOLIDAY SEASON.
SEE WHAT THAT HEADLINE SAYS,
HOLIDAY SALES POISED TO JUMP
ON U.S. JOB MARKET BOOM.
THAT IS THE KEY.
THE PRESIDENT WAS RIGHT, JOBS,
JOBS, JOBS.
IT'S ALL ABOUT JOBS.
PEOPLE ARE WORKING MORE AND
EARNING MORE AND THEY WILL
KEEP SPENDING.
THAT'S WHAT KEEPS THE ECONOMY
MOVING.
CONSUMER SPENDING IS TWO
THIRDS OF OUR ECONOMY.
THANKS TO THE TRUMP PROGRESS
POLICY AGENDA AMERICANS ARE
WORKING AND EARNING AT
HISTORIC LEVELS, BUT WE CAN'T
JUST SIT BACK AND HOPE IT GOES
ON, SEEMS TO ME THERE ARE FOUR
BIG THINGS THAT CAN BE DONE TO
KEEP IT MOVING FORWARD.
FIRST, THE FEDS CAN KEEP
CUTTING INTEREST RATES.
EVERYONE AGREES THEY MADE A
MASSIVE MISTAKE PUTTING THEM
UP, DAMPENING THE GROWTH WE
WERE SEEING.
THEY BEEN TRYING TO MAKE UP
FOR IT BUT THERE'S A LIMIT TO
WHAT THEY CAN DO.
SECOND, GET THE TRADE DEALS
DONE.
EVERYONE FOCUSES ON TRUMP'S
TRADE WARS WITH CHINA WHICH HE
DIDN'T START, HE'S JUST THE
FIRST PRESIDENT WHO'S ACTUALLY
FIGHTING BACK.
WHAT ABOUT TRUMP'S TRADE
PIECE.
YOU'VE GOT THEM SITTING THERE
WAITING FOR CONGRESS TO
APPROVE IT BUT ON TOP OF THAT
YOU'VE GOT DEALS OF SOUTH
KOREA, JAPAN, INDIA, THE EU.
IF ALL THESE GET DONE, THAT IS
A MASSIVE BOOST TO OUR
ECONOMY.
PASSIVE IN THE SENATE AND THEN
LET'S SEE IF NANCY POLICY
PELOSI THANKS IT'S.
[INAUDIBLE]
THE FOURTH THING THAT CAN BE
DONE TO KEEP THE ECONOMY
ECONOMY GROWING IS WHAT A
BUNKO TRUMP IS DOING.
LOOK AT THE DATA.
WE HAD 1.9 MILLION MORE
UNEMPLOYED THAN WE HAD JOB
OPENINGS.
THE TURNAROUND.
NOW WE HAVE ONE POINT TO
MILLION MORE JOB OPENINGS THEN
UNEMPLOYED.
THERE IS A SHORTAGE OF SKILLED